hi Fox this is episode 168 of
congratulations dude that's how we
started today word up
it is episode 168 and stop what you're
doing right now and go turn on Netflix
my special is dropping at midnight
you've probably if you're listening to
this podcast
honestly it's already dropped because
we're gonna drop this podcast late
Monday night but go turn on Netflix my
special no pain is out I've been working
real hard on this special I toured the
country and I toured other countries
mainly what I mean is pretty much just
Canada and I did a little bit of it in
Australia two years ago but I can't help
it your boys global so yeah my specials
out really want you to watch it work
really hard on it
I would love uh I would love your your
eyeballs to catch that [ __ ] you know I'm
really I'm really happy with it my
brother directed it my brother Matt alia
directed it he killed it fired my dad my
dad did my last three I told him hey
pops you're fired
hey brother you're hired and my dad goes
oh oh
best firing ever and it was a cool
moment and my brother and my brother
killed it but yeah so that comes out
that's out so turn that on and tell your
friends about that [ __ ] you know like I
said all the stars align with the
special the audience was there no
technical difficulties I loved
everything about it my brother killed it
production was great it was just awesome
and I was and I was happy about it and
I'm happy about the way it came out
anyway enough about that even though
I'll probably bring it up later um
how're you guys doing out there you
dodging Corona you dodging that Rona you
doing what I'm doing every now and then
you go uh-huh
do you do that every now and then do you
do this every now and then do I have a
sore throat
do you do that do you tell your
significant other give a sore throat no
I don't think I do either do you do that
like I do all the time is that what
you're doing just check-in uh so yeah um
it's a really bad bad thing
that is going on in this world and I
don't want to keep harping on it but you
know what's what's going on in the world
and I would be remiss if I didn't talk
about it wouldn't I babies right
remember when Trump was like oh you know
what there's 15 it's gonna go down to
zero or one next week and now there's
hundreds of thousands of people with it
and he didn't close down [ __ ] and people
and then people were like do you feel
like it's your it's your responsibility
and says I don't take right
responsibility who's that guy
everybody's dad that's how like a dad
would act sorry in my day
no no no no no no I don't take
responsibility of that that's your fault
mmm no talk back to your father
um dude I talked about [ __ ] pizza
gate last time and I've just been having
a [ __ ] whirlwind blast thinking about
the cameras on right thinking about
thinking about the people that this is
angered it's so uh it's so unbelievable
dude it's just hilarious that people
will I first of all I said there's
there's no like there's nothing going on
extra in Hollywood bad people are
everywhere
I'm just clarifying this because I also
like I like to talk about it and then
when people get mad I like to brush the
flames I like to go like this to the
argument because I don't know I like
reactions because some people just like
to watch the world burn the Joker he
said that the other one the Heath Ledger
one and people were just like oh so I I
started out you know yeah Harvey well
obviously there's people like Harvey
Weinstein and Kevin Spacey and these are
pretty much solo operators because
here's the deal
if you're gonna [ __ ] kids you're not
going to go out and and tell people
about it why because they'll turn yeah
and so I talked about this
on my podcast last time and people were
like oh bro [ __ ] what a shield Alya
is what a pedophilia she'll he is now by
the way I don't even know what she'll
means but I'll tell you something by the
way they're saying it I know I'm not
oh yeah Chris D'Elia way to [ __ ]
defend pedophilia hey man I'm not doing
that and the thing is you know it so -
dude it's so unbelievable man
oh look into this guy oh this guy
obviously was [ __ ] when he was a kid
he's covering it up people commented
that hey are you a real guy hey hey dude
I've got something to tell you this is
Earth that's not how it is imagine me
and I just got [ __ ] when I was a kid
just and I couldn't stand it hearing
about pizza gay because it drummed up
too much [ __ ] I was like no no that's
why I don't allow myself to believe that
somebody went to a place called [ __ ]
cosmos pizza in DC underground into a
basement that size of a closet and I had
a [ __ ] [ __ ] fest with Hillary Clinton
imagine that's why I didn't believe it
the reason why I don't believe it is do
people want to believe some [ __ ] so hard
they want to believe some [ __ ] so hard
because they just [ __ ] don't I get it
dude it's romantic as [ __ ] to think
about stuff and believe in it it's
romantic as [ __ ] you think I you think I
don't want to believe in Batman you
think I don't want to believe I am
Batman you think I don't want to believe
that [ __ ] you think I don't want to
believe that Harry Potter can go out
there and [ __ ] shoot shoot people and
turn them into pumpkins you think that I
don't want to believe that I do want to
believe that but I don't believe that
because of my brain because I'm 40
because I'm developed and because I have
things going on now I get it if you
don't have much going on then you want
to believe in this [ __ ] okay well let's
look at do your research that's my
favorite [ __ ] do your research do your
research bro
oh you mean [ __ ] google it you
can google anything you can google you
can Google right now probably monkeys
make maida an automobile and they were
[ __ ] a video will come up where
monkeys are making an automobile and
there'll be some guy in [ __ ] the
backwoods of Alabama like well you know
I had these pets and needed some help
with my cars and I just kind of left
them together you know with the old Ford
pickup and I don't know if it was them
technically or not but I woke up one day
and it was it was in much better
condition than when I left it and I
actually turned the key and it worked so
I'm not saying it was the monkeys but it
could have been that's a video that I
just made up that is absolutely a video
because the Internet has everything dude
do your research dude oh my god dude
he's a shill I love it I love it go
ahead believe it that's fine but it's
crazy how mad that's the thing I always
say is how come you can't just disagree
with somebody and not want them to be
[ __ ] like literally dead or dragged by
a [ __ ] horsey it's just so weird once
a comedian or anybody Tutt know a
comedian touches on and jokes about
something that you decide is too far you
get up in arms no no no [ __ ] that dude I
love Tupac talk [ __ ] make a joke go
ahead guess what
ha ha ha ha it's all good man no that's
our cool man to parks off limits go [ __ ]
yourself
nothing's off limits so if I'm talking
[ __ ] about pizza gate why because all of
a sudden you're a conspiracy theorist I
gotta shut the [ __ ] up why who are you
ever see that [ __ ] old Tim Meadows bit
on SNL he's like welcome to to 20
questions with whatever character he's
playing and then he asked one question
and then they're like they did they
answer it and then he says why and
there's and then there's a counter and
it goes to and then they answer that and
he says why and then it goes three and
he keeps going why four and they say
well I don't know because yada yada yada
why and he just does it 20 times and
then he says this has been 20 questions
with Tim Meadows Tim Meadows is so funny
and I want to say that he's the most
underrated SNL character
but I don't say people are underrated I
don't do that because that's a
backhanded compliment and let me tell
you about this conversation I had off of
a text chain now here's the deal
text chain arguments conversations
they're the hottest [ __ ] since lasagne
okay they really are they're the hottest
[ __ ] since the pipe and ass cheese goes
in your mouth and it gets and it dangles
too low but it's also outside of your
mouth so you end up going that [ __ ] when
you're a kid when you're a kid and
you're just like what do I pull it or
turn it suck it suck it further and as a
nine-year-old you're like hey it was
nice knowing y'all just dead with
crosses out over the eyes like a cartoon
Raggedy Ann doll anyway um [ __ ] what
was I talking about
the [ __ ] day what text chain I did
that [ __ ] hot text chain and I was do
it I think here's the thing about me
when I get into a [ __ ] hot argument
or a heated argument if my [ __ ] is
lasagna myself guess what dude I agree
with me that's how I know I'm right okay
I'll put out a tweet where I said
something like that and it got like
[ __ ] 20,000 likes so that's how you
know people feel the same so that's how
you know I'm right all right but my [ __ ]
is I [ __ ] agree with myself man a
backhanded compliment is to say somebody
is underrated and here's my thing my
friend said hey Rogan called
a Joe Rogan call on his Instagram called
Adam Sandler happy gilmore and
underrated underrated comedies and he
was like how could you call Adam Sandler
underrated comedy and I was like yeah
that's crazy he's like the number one
rated and then my friend was like well
saying that it's underrated maybe means
that you know because people maybe talk
[ __ ] about his movies they shouldn't be
talking [ __ ] about another that came in
that devolved into a whole conversation
is what is underrated is it okay to say
somebody's underrated or not like I have
fans come up to me and they said you're
underrated man I love you and what I
hear and maybe it's my insecure self I
hear people don't think that you're as
good as you should be but I do and to me
don't tell me any don't tell me you
don't like me don't allude to anything
about how peep
I mean just come up and say hey good job
hey thank you very much all right
so my buddy was calling me an idiot now
here's one here's here's here's one
thing we were doing the voice that's
texting so I can't read it we were
speaking into it and sending the shits
and my buddy was high as [ __ ] so first
of all his arguments out the door but
still he thought he was killing it so he
was like if somebody's saying you're
underrated if somebody's saying you're
underrated what they're saying is most
things that are rated highly speak to
the lowest common denominator in some
way so they're saying that those dummies
aren't smart enough to like you okay
and I'm saying no what you're doing is
adding a bunch of words to somebody
saying people don't like you as much as
I do and he was saying you're so wrong
how does it feel to be wrong and I'm
saying whatever I said something I would
write back and I [ __ ] agree with me
and he would be like that's the most
crystal ear thing ever to say and I go
you're damn right cuz I'm me dude and I
agree with me and my brother didn't
agree with me and my other friend didn't
agree with me and my other friend was
kind of on the fence but it was fine
because I knew I was right and that's
how we gotta live our lives dude from
from now on that's how we got to live
our lives man believe in what the [ __ ]
you're saying you ever talk to somebody
and they're like oh I don't know oh yeah
okay well alright like one time I was
working with a director and I saw him
talk to another actor and he was like
you want to try this and the actor
looked at me now we both locked eyes and
thought bad idea
whatever that director said awful idea
and the guy the other actor goes like
this I don't know I don't think that'll
work and the director goes like this
alright well I just thought was okay and
retreated backwards twisting his wrist
that's the most [ __ ] thing you can do
is just be like okay uh yeah
and so he did that and then that's it if
a director makes that one [ __ ]
retreat move twisty arm [ __ ] your movies
gonna suck bro your movies gonna suck
you could have done the revenant you
could have been like learn how to Caprio
get in that bear and they're not a
camper you'll be like I'll wait a beat
and then get in it and then you're like
okay uh okay that movie's gonna suck
[ __ ] Leonardo would be like [ __ ] that
we're all out here in the middle of
nowhere
gotta be out here and this was gonna
suck [ __ ] Eduardo lavon's korone or
whoever did that movie it's probably not
even that director that I'm trying to
[ __ ] think of um Eduardo lavon's
Corona you know um so you did the shape
of water whatever the [ __ ] that guy's
name is you know man I want to watch the
some movies I just want to watch so bad
and I just won't ever watch them like
shape of water I think it looks so
interested and then I go to look at it
on the [ __ ] Netflix or iTunes
whatever it is and then I look at it for
a little bit and I go yeah and I think
I'll die before I watch that movie and
it's probably great and people will be
like you should really go see it you
really should see it you really really
should see it won the Oscar and I go
like this yeah yeah yeah and I'll never
see it um anyway Eduardo allophones
karoon killed that [ __ ] movie
probably but I'm an ignoramus uh believe
in yourself is well I'm trying to say
don't [ __ ] out but yeah one time I went
to a man one time I was playing above
[ __ ] I must have been 21 and I was
beefy dude when I was 20 when I was
beefy you think the [ __ ] Lord of the
Rings have a place to shoot right now
bro forget that they did all those
movies back then okay right on the back
of my [ __ ] shoulders I would hear way
in the background oh yeah that's right
and dude like Eduardo lavon's cabron
could do [ __ ] revenant back here
revenant to t oo revenant also uh and so
uh I was with my buddy who is [ __ ]
goddamn hilarious intentionally and also
unintentionally like one time we were
talking about one time we were talking
we were mm-hmm
I was probably 23 this is before this is
after I'm doing it like pulp fiction I'm
doing a little bit here and then I'm
going back a little bit and they find
out I was dead at the end so he was like
he was like hey you know he wasn't
really getting chicks the way he wanted
to get chicks he wasn't getting laid and
he wanted to get laid because he was
[ __ ] twenty five six something
I mean and one time he was like I was
like well why don't you just like hit on
not as hot chicks you know you might
have a better chance and this way you
work your confidence up and then you
start hitting on you know hitting
hitting on and hook it up with the heart
attacks and he was like and he was
getting so frustrated at the time and he
would always do this that's how I
learned that this is [ __ ] he and he
said and dude I'll never forget this he
said he said he said I will not hook up
with some substandard girls I will not
talk up with substandard girls and dude
and I will never forget that
I will not hook up with substandard
girls and dude and I was like ah I think
that was the first time I went and it
was awesome and I laughed and that guy
hasn't been laid in two years now and
this is 20 years later I just talked to
him sadness real life sadness you think
shits going on dude
you think people are [ __ ] you think
what Corona the economy you think that
this shit's [ __ ] everything up my
buddy hasn't gotten laid for two years
sadness sadness you know what I mean
like that's that's brutally but you know
I guess it's the kind of thing like one
time when I was in a car pool I should
be carpool gonna kid going to school
with a kid with a bunch of different
kids in a van with that [ __ ] siding
that was like a wooden siding [ __ ]
whoever put cars with the wooden siding
on the outside it's like what are you
making a car or a [ __ ] house what is
the Breaking Bad how mobile so one time
and the kid the older kid he said yeah I
don't really watch TV I said really he
said yeah cuz one time I was grand I
couldn't watch TV all summer and then I
just came in got into the habit never
really wanted to watch TV and that's
what's happened with my buddy only what
it happens to do with getting his dick
wet and I'll tell you what that is 100%
not sensational so that is absolutely
not sensation that is absolutely not
sensation um anyway let's see I was
telling oh yeah so this is what I was
going back to it like I go back back
back my [ __ ] his steps I went a little
bit forward I went back and it's like
Timecop you go back and forth or Pulp
Fiction just in a different editing way
so
my [ __ ] time-travels okay so um thought
I just stepped in [ __ ] so anyway we
were doing this thing game with a bunch
of girls and guys and my buddy we had to
hum a song like the first few seconds of
a song and then whoever guessed it got a
point or some [ __ ] whatever it was the
[ __ ] worst game of all time and we
couldn't do the lyrics like you couldn't
be out there and just be like I'll put a
sign up right in the front window
advertisement right in the front window
and all of a sudden success coming out
of the blue because and you'd be like
Mushnik and son Little Shop of Horrors
of course right so so this guy was gonna
sing this song this guy was gonna sing
this song downtown right downtown right
whatever the [ __ ] that song is that was
probably in some Dustin Hoffman movie in
a 1981 so dumb that Aaron bump um
downtown right and it was his turn and
that was the song you wanted to sing
okay this is the most abit [ __ ] ever
okay there was a chin-up bar behind him
all right
in the room okay oh [ __ ] this dude there
was a chin-up bar behind him and he was
it was his Rosa okay go ahead and he
goes and then he goes downtown and
started crying the only thing he had to
do was not say downtown and he goes
downtown and we my other buddy and I who
we looked at each other immediate
beet-red faces and we started crying
like japanimation and then my buddy got
and embarrassed that he said the word
downtown that he [ __ ] pivoted
deena [ __ ] it was like he was tony
gwynn swinging the bat he just [ __ ]
twisted and walked over to the chin-up
bar and [ __ ] grabbed it and did two
chin-ups he did two [ __ ] chin up
stood out of business imagine being so
insecure and such that he was doing the
twist even when he was sitting he was
going downtown and then he realized that
it we [ __ ] started japanimation
crying and he twisted walked on over he
didn't run he walked like fast walk like
he would saw something that he wanted at
the mall real not really like really
quickly and then he just did two [ __ ]
chin-ups and oh my god dude I was 23 and
I knew that was a [ __ ] that guy hasn't
been laid in two years he didn't listen
he didn't listen
you know and we do live for the
congratulations podcast it's this
episode 168 make sure to check out
Krista Leah's no Peyton on Netflix
too-loud had it too loud in my your
headphones that was the jeremy renner
sting but yeah my special comes out
special comes out hi we're here live
with Chris D'Elia
sometimes you [ __ ] see those guys
when you used to I used to do a bunch of
press and stuff for like well on the
road you have to wake up at 6:30 in the
morning and you have to go to you'd have
to go to wherever if you're in like some
[ __ ] playing the Atlanta improv or
whatever it is and you go and you go
like 20 minutes away and go to some
radio station at 6 o'clock in the
morning and these guys you just hit on
them with tea and in front of their TV
you know in TV for the Morning News and
be like we've got Chris D'Elia here he's
all weekend at the Atlanta improv so
tell us Chris and they would be so close
you know you sit you don't think about
this but when you're doing an interview
with somebody you're really close to
them because they want to get it in one
shot you're not far away it looks weird
with there's too much space in between
so what happens is you're way closer
than you should be in real life but on
camera it looks nice alright and those
guys are the best because you can
they're the only guys in the world that
you can hear their face they're like so
so tell me
you got this new stuff going on so tell
me how it is to work material on the
road and they'll lean in and you can
hear their face because they got to keep
that smile plastered and it's cracking
and you feel it kind of JIT like just
kind of like cracking a little bit and
you can hear that it's very very small
but you can hear that and I just wanted
you to know that because we talked about
the most important news here and [ __ ]
congratulations podcast with Chris
D'Elia [ __ ] PR and I'll tell you man
so rude so anyway man that's kind of
what what's going on in my life my
special comes out make sure to check it
out and took it out and stuff
there was it [ __ ] guy oh my man I'm
thinking a lot of stuff when I was a kid
yo was that what fire was that from your
friends or was that from my friends
check it out and stuff oh yeah wait was
it judge Sanchez he does that oh [ __ ]
that was so funny I thought that was
like a high school friend this is not my
memory so [ __ ] up dude Johnny Sanchez
is [ __ ] hilarious dude anyway
that's right god I gotta ask him about
that
I went live on Instagram earlier today
and I had never it was like an hour ago
so you could check that out not that
that ever hears me I'm a podcast which
you shouldn't even be listening to
promoting my Instagram live that you
should even be listening to so but
Beiber [ __ ] asked to talk asked to do
the split screen and we did the split
screen and it's pretty cool that he did
that I never did split screen with
somebody but you know times are changing
and he said he's gonna watch my special
at midnight with his wife he that's very
cute yeah oh yeah okay I'll do ads now
that'll be a good time to do ads I'm
glad I thought of that dude that's like
that Grover character Super Grover and
you're like no a Super Grover I okay you
know like it was me okay okay Super
Grover better help is there something
interfere
with your happiness or is preventing you
from achieving your goals that's really
that's really unfortunate it's happened
with me I do it a lot with sleeping
sometimes I can't get to sleep I'm
stressed I've got stuff going on you
know now with the kid I'm like stressed
about the kid stressed about my family
stuff like that mm-hmm but better help
will assess your needs and match you
with your own licensed professional
therapist you can start communicating in
under 24 hours isn't that amazing it's
not a crisis line it's not self-help
it's professional counseling done
securely online now here's what I always
always thought about professional
counseling you get your car tuned up why
wouldn't you get your brain tuned up the
service is available available for
clients worldwide you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule a weekly video or phone session
so you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room man you could
do it just like that plus you can't even
chat and text with your therapist
between sessions that's great
visit better help calm / Congrats and
join the over 500,000 people taking
charge of their mental health with the
help of an experienced professional
congratulations listeners get 10% off
your first month at better help calm /
Congrats shipstation as folks adapt to
this changing world and this world trust
me is ever changing we're all going to
be buying more stuff online than ever
before I do all the time err as every
day goes by I buy more stuff online the
other day I bought a car online not
really if you're an e-commerce seller
are you ready to meet the demands of our
new delivery culture be ready be ready
that's the one thing you gotta be and
you can be ready with shipstation why
shipstation to probably send Chris by
ship station
well you're selling online and when
you're selling online getting a lot of
orders out fast can be tough how do you
keep traffic track of who gets what
which ship and carrier should you use
are you getting the best rates that's
what you need ship station comm I use
ship station for all my merch my fans
always tweet me about how fast they get
their orders if you're selling something
ship station is the way to go it's so
easy no matter where you're selling
Amazon Etsy your own website ship
station brings all your orders into one
simple interface making them really easy
to manage from
device even your cell phone and right
now congratulations listeners can try
shipstation free for 60 days when you
use offer code Congrats make sure your
business is ready to meet the demands of
delivery culture get started with
shipstation comm today click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in congrats that's shipstation
comm then enter offer code congrats ship
station comm make ship happen get it so
yeah god that pizza good thing is so
funny my Netflix special is out
everybody go check it out watch this
special or watch this
speaking of Netflix I watched this show
because I was watching Breaking Bad and
just needed a break you know me and
wifey watch him break him bad I needed a
[ __ ] break because it's too it's just
too intense and we were like let's
retire Breaking Bad and let's watch
doomsday preppers now she wanted to go
to sleep it pissed me off all good I
wanted to stay awake and watch doomsday
preppers too [ __ ] kind of cancel out
that Breaking Bad now does it piss me
off yes is it okay sure it's fine
somebody's got to get up at 6 a.m. and
feed my baby but I've watched doomsday
preppers and these people are like the
people that think that the pizza gate is
real I watched two episodes because
that's how I do when some shits on
Netflix sometimes I've watched two
episodes I don't watch three or four
unless it's like some real hot [ __ ] but
sometimes I'd like to test [ __ ] out I'd
like to dip my toes in the netflix water
you know what I mean I like to do that
if something's called doomsday preppers
you've got them right now how much the
whole thing but I'm gonna dip my toe in
it because I'm a Curious George okay and
if you have a problem with that then get
to steppin these people are [ __ ] nuts
though how about that it's actually a
really good well put together show these
guys talk about these guys talk about
the world like they're scared of like
you
terrorists attack someone guys in a
mobile home and he just drives
everywhere and he drives [ __ ]
everywhere and he's got like satellite
hooked up he could be blogs from his
[ __ ] I forget what his name is but he's
online and [ __ ] he's got a podcast that
he does from his mobile home and he just
keeps driving dude and he's got like a
crossbow and guns just in case and he
sets up the security cameras so he can
see he'd sent he heat coming to it it's
like and he's just like look man if a
terrorist attack comes I'm gonna be on
I'm gonna be on the road I'm gonna drive
to where it's safe and they're like well
what about gas and he's like well that's
my only thing that I'm worried about I
have like a year's worth of supplies
eating wise in my in my trunk here and
he's got like [ __ ] [ __ ] that he needs
to plant and like dried food that he
needs to add water to and he makes his
own water and [ __ ] he makes everything
and it's just so insane and I'm just
like dude how are you running from
terrorism every day of your life
not sure if something's gonna happen in
the meantime
you're not living your [ __ ] life like
dude if terrorists are gonna get me he's
like he's like because you know how I
win he's like me stay in mobile that's
how I win and I go like this out loud to
wifey I say he lost already and she goes
and I'm more pissed what got [ __ ] for
watching doomsday preppers excuse me
[ __ ] doomsday preppers this on you know
she goes like this a lot when we're
watching TV it's too loud and I'm just
like four [ __ ] ho dude could you just
turn the lower wolf or [ __ ] what I
get pissed yes yeah you guys enjoy
[ __ ] quarantine to Easter did you do
that another guy was on do another guy
was on doomsday preppers and he was
underground what about the Sun hey dude
are you a [ __ ] gopher what about a
Sun what about the Sun another guy was
on what was the other guy was another
guy that was oh he was he had a
self-sustainable [ __ ] he's like I
don't have any more cash he's gotta have
money I barely I don't have any bills
though the only thing I have bills
honors is his cell phone and I have
enough money to cover my cell phone for
a few years and he was like and I don't
even need to you know if a cell phone
who cares if I have a cell phone tonight
and his wife is like yeah let's go
practice shooting things in the yard and
he was like okay and they get he got
[ __ ] the only time I'm never gonna
use it is during this [ __ ] show
doomsday preppers also he was like
that's the thing if invaders come to
find my place cuz my place is really
good then I could [ __ ] ward them off
with these guns and we've got places in
my yard that we have coolers of [ __ ] of
food and bullets and guns and sniper
rifles and he was like so we're good and
I'm like but what about the show but
what about how everyone's gonna see
where you live now because it's on
Netflix and everybody's watching Netflix
watch my special it's streaming now no
pain but yeah that's like that whole
thing when it was when it's like when
it's like when they show like the
[ __ ] movies or another movie sorry
the docu-series is where it's like about
gang life real deal or whatever they all
the [ __ ] titles are the same
it's like gang life blood for glory
gang life real-deal streets the streets
of LA gang life Bloods versus [ __ ] the
lifestyle blood blood blood in blood out
gang life gang gang gang and [ __ ]
gang and with the [ __ ] gang Gerson's
you know it's all name the same [ __ ] and
and their and then you get the guy that
was like this was a top done of the
couple of the [ __ ] game of the
[ __ ] Crips from 1980 to 1995 and he
was just like yeah man you know we had
to kill my [ __ ] just for looking at
us the wrong way ma'am
we killed about three former [ __ ]
just looking at us the wrong way we
killed by three more [ __ ]
former [ __ ] looking at us the wrong
way and we killed much more than that
from
[ __ ] who do a much modena if you know
what I mean and I'm just at home like
hey get him this is TV are you
confessing on videotape
get him our cops watch what cops are at
home and just like [ __ ] him up dude I
know watch I'm not going to get him
where am I going but in a [ __ ]
Jacksonville because that's where all
crimes happen if a crime didn't happen
in Jacksonville guess what didn't happen
that's my whole motto that's how I'm
gonna run for [ __ ] mayor of Los
Angeles if a crime didn't happen in
Jacksonville it didn't happen
mayor of Jacksonville Jacksonville
[ __ ] sucks anyway uh Jekyll doesn't
suck dude I've had some [ __ ] awesome
shows in Jacksonville I'm just playing
dude ladies um plantain ladies anon love
you I'm playing I'm playing you know I
love you um yeah bro I'm a nosy neighbor
bro just so you know I'm a nosy neighbor
just so you [ __ ] know what are you
gonna do about that hey dude is looking
illegal no peeping is but I'm not
peeping
I'm just looking I took a walk with my
family the other day just looking exited
the house took a walk left you know the
difference
I don't do this peeping I'll just stick
my face in the brush I'm Pete I'm not
peeping I'm looking dude and then they
go like this stop peep and then I go I
wasn't using my hands this is a free
country isn't that right Chris come on
come on let's go everyone he's crying
bro I don't peep is it what are you
doing dude
oh you're on a walk oh dude I look in
backyards yeah yeah don't looking do I
look ins bro hey [ __ ] are like
you looking you lookin backyards bro I
look I'm so gangster I look inside yards
you understand me if you got a [ __ ]
branch that's not covering that's where
my eyes go man that's where my [ __ ]
eyes go so if I'm taking a stroll which
I am right now cuz kovat if I'm taking a
[ __ ] stroll and there's a and your
branch [ __ ] up if your branch was
going to cover it but the Sun hit it
weird and it started to grow that way my
face goes right there and I ain't
peeping them but I'm looking and you got
nice ass furniture dude you got a pool
in a tennis court and I can see both
sides
you understand me dude and if you have a
side yard I'm all over that [ __ ] cuz
it's easy to see side yards can't see my
backyard my backyards hidden
go ahead peep go ahead try to look hey
try to look at my [ __ ] go ahead go ahead
I survey the [ __ ] area branches grown
the wrong way
I [ __ ] move the branches you can't
see [ __ ] [ __ ] and I have cool
neighbors and they can't see [ __ ] I have
cool neighbors dude one super famous
that I won't even tell you who but uh
yeah dude so I don't peep but I look
dude when someone drives by hey what are
you doing oh okay that's illegal no I
have my hands in my pocket they have a
hole for my face I'm just looking yeah
[Music]
there's [ __ ] low holes - I'm gonna
tell my son [ __ ] go ahead when you
start walking you can use those low
holes to look in check out the side yard
buddy [ __ ] can't wait I can't wait to
teach my son almost illegal [ __ ] you
know what I mean almost illegal [ __ ] and
then it goes like yeah but that isn't
that bad and I go like this not if you
know the words how to describe it not if
you know how to describe it not if you
know how to describe it but isn't peepin
bad excuse me son we're just looking oh
I get it now look in that papen yeah so
I got in I got a question too about only
fans and I know I've talked about this
and I caught some heat on the podcast
but if I'm not catching heat I'm not
relevant so throw the heat my way man
this shit's hot I'm ready but only fans
is an interesting thing because why do
girls do it okay now I don't mean why do
all girls do it but I'm what I mean is
why do all the girls who do it do it now
that's different now if you were my
buddy on a texture and you would argue
that this is the same and I would get
mad and I would say too late I agree
with me but all the girls who do it
don't need to do it most of the girls
that would do it I would argue don't
wanna be doing it do you know why
because they're showing you their fried
butterflied but fried butterfly and if
you need any more explanation than than
that this conversation or podcast isn't
for you because one time I was like hey
Dad
my dad said yeah we were at a basketball
game for some [ __ ] reason who was I
but my dad was like we were talking
about porn porn and porn and my dad was
like yeah I don't know I always thought
was kind of odd when a girl was a porn
star and I was like wanted to be wanted
to do porn I was like why he was like I
don't know I feel like you know maybe it
means like something
happen in your childhood or whatever and
makes you fit whatever he was saying I
don't know if we're gonna want to out
them you know but I was like yeah but
you could probably be a really full
complete well-adjusted person and still
do porn and he was like yeah I guess
you're right but then it's like he said
but then it's like imagine you're like
yeah I'm a well-adjusted person I could
get a real job and I can do things and I
have hopes and dreams but instead of
that I just want guys to come on my face
and I was like hmm very good point okay
and we were at the Clippers game who was
I why why do why were we there he got
free tickets or some [ __ ]
so only fans is interesting because it's
that whole thing where it's like why
doesn't every girl on Instagram have at
least 20,000 followers like you can do
it girl you can do anything cuz your
girl and guys are dumb a lot of those
girls would take a sugar daddy
a lot of those girls would just marry
for money a lot of those girls are
really hot if you're hot why are you
doing only fans if deep down you just
want to marry a [ __ ] you don't have
to [ __ ] do all that [ __ ] because
people who do only fans for the same
thing goes for people who do Instagram
for for money you don't guys girls
whatever I'm this isn't this is not a
sexist thing but like you know you don't
want to work that hard you know what I'm
talking about
you don't want to work that hard that's
why you're [ __ ] going like this hey
$3 to see my [ __ ] right so what are you
doing doing it it's so interesting to
think about look I love that there's
only fans and I love when people do only
fans because love see and tits
love seeing tits I got it man I see a
Drake yeah but it's just so fascinating
man that some [ __ ] this kovat thing app
and I get it and you're like well I
can't go out
work so [ __ ] I want to show you my
[ __ ] so that's guy get that make your
[ __ ] money dude for the people that
really want to do it do it
I guess this may be just like being in
another job it's like yeah I don't wanna
be [ __ ] bagging groceries or whatever
or at cratenbarrel ringing up these
[ __ ] [ __ ] plates but it's just
kind of what I fell into I guess it's
the same thing we figured it out but hot
girls can just get a free ride man they
can literally get a free ride like a
literal free ride like a hot girl can
see you drive by and be like scuse me
and you'll go and be like yes sweetheart
and it goes like can I get a ride and
you're like I wasn't going that way but
100% hop on in literally you can get a
free ride so what are you doing
jiggling your ted's but don't stop we
love them ladies new moms is jungle you
know I'm plant anyway who knows if I'll
get [ __ ] cancer because I said all
that what was I gonna do ads let me get
ads dude can't find him so awesome one I
can't find it here we go
Bambi when running a business HR issues
can kill you
wrongful termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations and HR
manager salaries aren't cheap
alright an average of seventy thousand
dollars a year hello Bambi spelled B am
b ee was created specifically for small
businesses you can get a dedicated HR
manager craft HR policy and maintain
your compliance all for just night
you're probably like okay but fine what
is it 40 G's a year dude $99 a month
what thanks Bambi that's awesome with
Bambi you can change HR from your
biggest liability to your biggest
strength and that's important my babies
your dedicated HR manager is available
by phone email or real-time chat from
onboarding determinations that customize
your policies to fit your business and
they help you manage your employees day
to day or just
$9.00 a month go to Bambi calm /
Congrats right now to schedule your free
HR audit that's Bambi calm / Congrats
spelled B a.m. to the B e.com / congrats
to the they had me say like I'm a white
guy in 2008 uh manscaped you guys heard
me talk about this man I was just
thinking about this the other day when I
was shaving my I don't shave my balls
but I was you know what I mean I was
thick I was actually thinking about this
the other day while I was not shaving my
balls I wasn't even touching my balls
but I was thinking about manscaped and I
was thinking about how it's really cool
to get that extra straggly hair if
you're bored in the house bored in look
if you're bored the house when I play
with your balls okay you know that
that's what I always say our sponsor
today manscaped is here to make sure
your balls are smooth while you or your
partner are playing with them understand
manscaped promotes clean hygiene when it
comes to shaving your balls
thanks to their lawn mower 3.0 manscaped
is the only men's brand dedicated to
below the waist grooming and hygiene I
love doing it the perfect tools for your
family jewels you see how it rhymes
perfect for your family jewels the
perfect package 3.0 skit kit comes with
the new and improved lawn mower 3.0
waterproof cordless body trimmer and a
ton of other liquid formula formulations
to round out your manscaping routine and
of course let's not forget the crop
preserver and anti chafing ball you are
in and moisturizer you already put urine
on your armpits right why don't we put
children on your balls you don't want
them to smell bad I don't have my armpit
smell them a ball smell so get it going
more bang for your buck man when you
purchase the new perfect package 3.0 kit
at manscape comm for limited time
subscribers get not one but two free
gifts the shed travel bag $39 value and
the patent high-performance anti chafing
manscaped boxer-brief this is the
perfect package for your perfect package
get 20% off and free shipping with the
code babies at manscape comm that's 20%
off with Free Shipping at manscape calm
and use code babies make playing with
your balls the best part of your day
thanks manscaped
so my special does come out it's out now
and my brother did direct it and I just
want to say I'm really fortunate man I
really am fortunate sure I worked hard
and stuff but I'm really lucky to be in
the position that I am and I realized
that and I try I do think about that a
lot and and my brother directed this
special and it's just so cool that he
did it because I love him and I mean I
really love him like it's so awesome to
have somebody like that like people
always say like oh how many kids you
want to have and I'm like two's good
because I had one brother and no sisters
and no other brother and everything that
I didn't could couldn't talk to anybody
about I would do it with Matt because he
was the only guy and that bond because
of that is awesome now I'm not saying if
you have three brothers or two sisters
and a brother or whatever you don't have
that but for me I always felt cool that
there was one other person that I can
confide in and just know that that
[ __ ] was down to ride and so was
i for him and of course I had an open
you know family with my mom my dad I
could talk to them about everything I
mean the first time I masturbated I
walked down and I told them and I walked
down and I said and I was crying and for
real dude I was a [ __ ] and I and I said
to my mom and my mom said what the
hell's wrong she was eating like [ __ ]
jelly beans my mom would always eat the
jelly beans and she would shuck him
around her hand a little bit before she
popped them in her mouth dude it drove
me nuts I was like why don't you just
pick him up and [ __ ] eat him what if
to make it a game like that he needs a
new pair of shoes a there we go
but I was crying and she was like what's
wrong and I said it happened and I
thought she knew what I was gonna talk
about she said what and I said coming
and she said I [ __ ] go upstairs your
dad's coming home in ten minutes and
that was what I got to talk about the
birds and the bees and that is beautiful
but anything I couldn't bring up I would
talk to my brother about
and you know I assume my brother did the
same thing to me we never hated each
other you know I think he went through
some weird [ __ ] because I was the older
brother and just you know it's weird
when you growing up with an older
brother I feel like probably have to
like you know he did I did everything
first you know and then the the second
kid is like okay the second kid we
learned our mistakes and it's you know
it's like if you have 11 kids the 11th
kid is this like oh yeah what's his name
again you know so I feel like really
cool that my brother I feel lucky that
my brother directed it because he's
great first of all he's talented but
besides that I love him and I genuinely
love him deeply and to have him a part
of this experience helps me you know I
mean it was that way with my dad too it
was the coolest thing he was in he was
in the van I'm er when I shot my first
special he was in the van with the
headphones on and I knew out there on
stage he was proud of me in that van you
know and I would think about that while
I was doing my special while I was
[ __ ] talking to those people in New
Orleans and I got in my head a little
bit with stand up through the years like
incorrigible I felt good about and then
I started getting a little bit insecure
because I didn't know what else to talk
about mana fire was something that came
out after encouraged was my third
special and the material I had I loved
but I just wasn't in a good place in my
life and my dad directed it and it was
great I'm really proud of it and I was
still in my head I shot comedians of the
world I really like the way it came out
I don't I'm lucky to have what I have
and I'm lucky to have shot what I have
shot in my career but man but this
special no pain which is one of the
reasons why it's called no pain because
people always a pain comedy comes from
pain but I didn't really [ __ ]
experience much of that in my life and
I'm fortunate for that and I always used
to think that it was it would make me
insecure as it made me insecure that I
didn't have that real [ __ ] to talk about
as a comedian and and this one is just
like [ __ ] all that
I have what I haven't I'm really [ __ ]
lucky and I'm really fortunate and I'm
gonna talk about what the [ __ ] I'm gonna
talk about and I'm like I have my dad
I'm like I have my mom I'm like I have
my own family you know and my brother
directed it and that's a real [ __ ]
special thing for me man and so you know
thank you Matt for doing it and you made
it great you know it's cool to have a
support system I don't know I don't know
if that's what you wanted to hear or not
wanted to hear I mean sometimes I talk
like that and then people end up [ __ ]
being like [ __ ] you bro because oh you
don't know what real pain is and it's
like okay but some people [ __ ] you
know I look I'm just trying to be honest
with you guys sometimes but yeah so I'm
excited I'm really [ __ ] excited and
thanks for to everybody that ever has
come out to see me and [ __ ] supported
me online or even if you haven't come
out to see me if you just [ __ ] tell
somebody I'm funny that's so cool
and I appreciate that um what else that
I wanted to talk about sorry I wanted to
[ __ ] some serious [ __ ] there but I
want to talk about something else that
was funny what was it I have it right
here the [ __ ] person who said that
dessert is gay did you see this this
[ __ ] chick tweets of course changed
no I don't [ __ ] have it here we go a
guy ordering dessert on a date is a red
flag for me that's a female thing to do
for real dis girl writes and then she
writes if a guy is on a date with a
woman the woman should be the only one
asking for appetizers and dessert many
meals in capital like seriously you can
just taste some of whatever I ordered
what the friggin [ __ ] is wrong with this
girl you know to actually be like I
liked it first of all I like that she
has a heart opinion on appetizers that's
my [ __ ] dude to have a hard opinion
about nothing that's right in my [ __ ]
wheelhouse but this checked
and then she went on to say something
like order two meals if you're extra
hungry but don't get dessert imagine a
girl be first of all since when is not
since when is eating the most not what a
man does
I eat [ __ ] two meals I eat my meal
scarf it down and I wait for my lady to
finish that [ __ ] and when she doesn't I
go oh yeah I'm like that guy in that
yellow suit behind the tree meme oh yeah
I'm like that guy bro that shit's going
in my mouth when my lady does to me
sometimes I'm out to dinner dinner it's
like I'm a cleaning lady sometimes I'm
out to dinner with my [ __ ] her in my
opener or some [ __ ] and she's like you
want to him and I'm like [ __ ]
that's mine bro and I tell him I stopped
it with him sometimes I say just so you
know when she tries to offer you some
[ __ ]
it's not yours it's mine you understand
me and he goes I'm always up to her and
I said no it's not bro being a man is
eating at all being a man is eating at
all it's like that old Kenny Loggins
song being the man who's eating at home
[ __ ] two meals and the certain
appetizer yeah but yeah dude I like that
she had a hard description a hard
opinion not description very weird have
a brain tumor all good um and then
people take it serious seriously you
know one day you will learn that the
only thing that that's gay is
homosexuality feminist traits and anal
kinks are not gay definitely not eating
dessert perhaps others as well yeah all
right thanks for the [ __ ] break live
news week how many live do is we could
this just in no one day you'll learn
that only the only thing that's gay is
homosexuality feminine traits and anal
kinks are not gay definitely not eating
dessert or appetizers as well LMFAO
Oh anal kinks are not gay
tonight at 11 our anal kinks gay tuning
to find out you can't wait till 11 our
anal tinks gay dude our a our anal kinks
gay or are they just sensational
sensational anal kinks you know just say
ass [ __ ] if a girl straps on a dick
and [ __ ] a guy in the ass that's not
gay straight up it's not gay you're
[ __ ] a girl it's not gay
I know people be like you know the
brothers like to be like hey ya ain't
gon do that [ __ ] you know I mean but
like bro it's not gay you're [ __ ] a
girl you're [ __ ] the girl with a
strap-on if a girl puts a strap-on it
[ __ ] your but you're not gay you like a
strap-on in your button if you [ __ ] a
guy and he's [ __ ] you in the butt
gay that's it that's the rule if you're
kissing on some dude and you jerk off a
little bit the dude and also yourself
you got two dicks in your hands about
one of them's yours okay if a girl with
tits and a [ __ ] and no dicks straps on
the dicks and [ __ ] you in the butt
that's it you're partying with a chick
in your stride as a [ __ ] rolling
with the homies and I a [ __ ] and a
[ __ ] best part about it is I agree
with myself heard dr. Drew say it on
[ __ ] love line once in 1999 so I know
it's true rollin with the homies so
dessert imagine you think desserts gay
I imagine this girl thinks if a girl
straps on a [ __ ] dick and plugs your
butthole with it that is definitely gay
what if the guy ordered dessert and then
afterward when you hook up with him he's
like we put this on in front of my butt
she would be like pew and arrived at her
nest that's ignition like this bracket
to kick I could kick the guy with the
dildo
the guy with the dill just I've never
had anything in my ass um I didn't like
talking about this yet but I really
haven't and and uh and I was talking to
a guy once and he was like yeah I
haven't either one time when I was in
the shower I tried to put when I was
younger I tried to put a little bit of a
shampoo bottle in my butt and it felt
kind of good but that's all I ever did
and I was like Kay but I didn't I didn't
I never had anything in my blood I don't
know it just seems like it would be
uncomfortable who knows I don't know
that's a hard stance though people don't
really agree with me on that dr. Diedre
dr. drew does in 1999 though players
[Music]
buck what else man do I have anything
else to talk about I forget who were
right at an hour we did at my babies I'm
sweaty dude this shirt it says back up
the Brinks truck it's it's fan-made
somebody gave it to me like four five
years ago at an improv somewhere he was
like my dad makes shirts here back and
only no it was it wasn't it's like four
years ago I guess how long holds his
podcast is when I was saying the [ __ ]
quitter quitter quitter treshtoons
Twitter questions for my foghorn leghorn
um Chris Thalia how [ __ ] is it to
throw something out of anger and then
have to go pick it up scene food
shopping today from Graham Jay 42
yeah that's that's pretty good that's
pretty [ __ ] I mean it all depends on
how you do it if jason statham that it
will be less [ __ ] than it [ __ ] Bill
Gates did it you know what I mean if I
got if you tuck in your shirt
pretty much whatever you're gonna do is
has a little bit of an added [ __ ]
here's another one Greg cash
hey hey Chris Thalia at and congrats
spot crazy spot when we getting a collab
of Eminem and Chang Smith yeah I mean
dude you know I'm all for it you
probably you might want to talk to the
stork you probably have to ask him in
them about that because I'm all in but I
doubt that'll ever happen
Hannah Mercer at jump off a boat hmm
do people ever take photos of you from a
distance without approaching you yeah of
course that's what people used to get
mad at me I don't really do this too
much anymore but I used to I used to
film people from a distance and make
jokes and stuff and put on my Instagram
and [ __ ]
and I started to feel bad doing that my
whole thing was yeah but but people
people recorded me way more than a
record anybody else oh [ __ ] that I think
that that was maybe the wrong way to
look at it I felt bad doing that I still
do it every now and then if their face
isn't really enough I don't like putting
people on blast like I have too many
followers like I feel bad doing it but
yeah people do it to me all the time
when I catch people doing I walk right
up to him bro I walked right up it when
I say hey if you want to pick just ask
that's some gangster [ __ ] and only one
time I was wrong the guy wasn't taking
pictures he was just trying to find cell
service so I felt really shitty um I was
like hey man if you want a picture just
as he said ha I was just looking for
service and I said I'm David Copperfield
and then I ran away
none of that happened I made up that
last part I've got to be honest on the
[ __ ] congratulations podcast anyway
you guys are great
so that's what's up that's it and let's
see was there anything else I wanted to
talk about desserts gay people say
desserts gay this desserts gay I'm on
your mom's house with Tom Segura drops
tomorrow I'm doing Rogen tomorrow my
special comes out man it's gonna be
Krystal Lia day if you ever watched any
video of me on YouTube that [ __ ] is
gonna be Chris D'Elia for you when you
[ __ ] open up your [ __ ] I'll tell you
that much man my shits gonna be [ __ ]
up the algorithm I'm trying to [ __ ]
break the internet man no pain comes out
it's out no pains out streaming on
Netflix
watch it you guys are great thank you so
much for supporting me can't wait for
you to see my new special on Netflix and
that's it really you could text me the
number is you just go to my Instagram
and
text you can text me on there and tweet
me and use that hashtag no pain Netflix
that helps me out because then I can see
it I click on that hashtag no pain
Netflix if you're watching it let me
know and and maybe I'll do a watch party
a little bit later about the [ __ ] and we
can all watch it together but thank you
guys you guys are great
and that's it bye bye
[Music]
all right I'm turning this off now